i want to talk a little bit about direct
and inverse variation so i'll do direct
variation on the left over here and i'll
do
inverse variation or two variables that
very very inversely on the right hand
side over here so a very simple
definition for two variables that vary
directly would be something like this y
it varies directly with x if y is equal
to
some constant with x so we could rewrite
this in kind of english as y
varies
directly
with
with x and if this constant seems
strange to you this just remember this
could be literally any constant number
so let me give you a bunch of examples
that would also be or i guess particular
examples of y varying directly with x
you could have y is equal to x because
in this situation the constant is one we
didn't even write we could write y is
equal to one x then k is one we could
write y is equal to two x we could write
y is equal to one half x we could write
y is equal to negative 2x we are still
varying directly we could have y is
equal to negative one-half x we could
have y
is equal to pi
times x we could have y is equal to
negative pi times x i think i don't want
to beat a dead horse now i think you get
the point any constant times x we are
varying directly and to understand this
maybe a little bit more tangibly let's
think about what happens and let's pick
one of these scenarios let's well i'll
take a positive version and a negative
version just because it might not be
completely intuitive so let's take the
version of y is equal to 2x and let's
explore why we say they vary directly
with each other
so let's pick a couple of values for x
and a couple of val and see what the
resulting y value would have to be so if
x is equal to 1 then y is 2 times 1 or
is 2.
if x is equal to 2
then y is 2 times 2 which is going to be
equal to 4. so when we doubled x when we
went from 1 to 2 so we doubled x the
same thing happened to y
we doubled we doubled y so that's what
it means when something varies directly
if we scale x up by a certain amount
we're going to scale up y by the same
amount if we scale down y by x by some
amount we would scale down y by the same
amount and just to show you it works
with all of these let's try the
situation
with y is equal to negative 2x
i'll do it in magenta
y
is equal to
negative well let me do a new example
that i haven't read here let's try y is
equal to negative
negative 3x so once again let me do my x
and my y when x is equal to 1 y is equal
to negative 3 times 1 which is negative
3.
when x is equal to 2
y so negative 3 times 2 is negative 6.
so what notice we multiplied
so if we scaled let me do that in that
same green color
if we scale up x by 2 it's a different
green color but it serves a purpose
we're also scaling up y by 2. to go from
1 to 2 you multiply by 2 to go from
negative 3 to negative 6 you're also
multiplying by 2. so we grew by the same
scaling factor and if you wanted to go
the other way let's say if we went to
let's try
i don't know let's go to 1
x is one-third
if x is one-third then y is going to be
negative 3 times 1 3 is negative 1. so
notice to go from 1 to 1 3
we divide by 3. to go from negative 3 to
negative 1 we also divide by 3. we also
scale down by a factor of 3. so however
whatever direction you scale x in you're
going to have the same scaling direction
as y that's what it means to vary
directly now it's not always so clear
sometimes it will be obfuscated so you
could write
so let's take this example right over
here
y is equal to negative 3x i'm saving
this real state for inverse variation in
a second you could write it like this or
you could algebraically manipulate it
you could maybe divide both sides of
this equation by x
and then you would get y over x is equal
to
negative 3
or maybe you divide both sides by x and
then you divide both sides by y so from
this you could get so if you divide both
sides by y now you could get 1 over x is
equal to negative 3 times 1 over y
these three statements these three
equations are all saying the same thing
so sometimes the direct variation isn't
quite in your face but if you do
this this what i did right here with any
of these you will get the exact same
result
or you could just try to manipulate it
back to this form over here and there's
other ways we could do it we could
divide both sides of this equation by
negative three and then you would get
negative 1 3 y is equal to x
and now this this is kind of an
interesting case here because here this
is x varies directly with y
or we could say x is equal to k sum k
times y and in general that's true if y
varies directly with x then we can also
say that x varies
varies directly with
y
it's not going to be the same constant
it's going to be essentially the inverse
of that constant but they're still
directly varying now with that said so
much said about direct variation let's
explore inverse variation a little bit
inverse variation the general form if we
use the same variables and it always
doesn't have to be y and x it could be
an a and a b it could be a
it could be a m and an n i'm just you
know if i said m varies directly with n
we would say m is equal to some constant
times n now let's do inverse variation
so if i did it with y's and x's this
would be y is equal to some constant
times 1 over x so instead of being some
constant times x it's some constant
times 1 over x so let me draw you a
bunch of examples it could be y is equal
to 1 over x it could be y is equal to
two times one over x which is clearly
the same thing as two over x it could be
y is equal to one third times one over x
which is the same thing as one over 3x
it could be
y is equal to negative 2 over x and
let's explore this the inverse variation
the same way that we explored the direct
variation so let's pick i don't know
let's pick y is equal to 2 over x y is
equal to 2 over x
and let me do that same table over here
so i have my table and my x values and
my y values if x is 1
x is 1 then y is 2.
if x is 2
then 2 divided by 2 is 1. so if you
multiply x by 2. if you scale it up by a
factor of 2 what happens to y
y gets scaled down by a factor of 2.
you're dividing by 2 now notice the
difference here whatever however we
scaled x we scaled up y by the same
amount now if we scale up x by a factor
when we have inverse variation we're
scaling down y by that same so that's
where the inverse is coming from and we
could go the other way if we made x is
equal to one-half so if we were to scale
down
if we were to scale down x we're going
to see that it's going to scale up y
because two divided by one half is four
so here we are scaling up y so they're
going to do the opposite things they
vary they vary inverse and you could try
it with the negative version of it as
well so here we're multiplying we're
multiplying by two
and once again it's not always neatly
written for you like this it can be
rearranged in a bunch of different ways
but it could there as it would still be
inverse variation as long as they're
algebraically equivalent so you could
multiply both sides of this equation
right here by x
and you would get x y
is equal to 2. this is also inverse
variation you would get this exact same
table over here you could divide both
sides of this equation by y and you
could get x is equal to
x is equal to 2
over y which is also the same thing as 2
times 1 over y so notice
y varies inversely with x and you can
just manipulate this algebraically to
show that x varies inversely with y
so x so y varies
inversely
with x
this is the same thing as saying and we
just showed it over here with a
particular example that x
varies
inversely
inversely with y and there's other
things we could take this and divide
both sides by 2 and you would get y over
2 is equal to 1 over x there's all sorts
of crazy things and so in general if you
see an expression for that relates to
variables and they say do they vary
inversely or directly or maybe neither
you could either try to do a table like
this if you scale up x by a certain
amount and y gets scaled up by the same
amount then it's direct variation
if you scale if you scale up x by some
amount you might want to try it a couple
of different times and you you scale
down y do the opposite with y then it's
probably inverse variation the more the
the more
i guess surefire way of knowing what
you're dealing with is to actually
algebraically manipulate the equation so
it gets back to either this form which
would tell you that it's inverse
variation or this form which would tell
you that it is direct variation